[Music]
morning sir our travel time to Shanghai
is 11 hours 15 minutes told you we
should have taken the faster flight I
think the board prefers you wear a more
conventional suit to these company
meetings you can't outrun your past
Friday tell me I didn't just imagine
that negative sir
a little late don't you think
Friday suit up now
[Music]
time to the hero fake
while stealth inbound 10 o'clock so much
for a hero's welcome
oh yeah right
any idea who we're up against you made
your share of enemies sir illegal time
I love you that's how it's done
threat neutralized good I have a plane
to catch
[Music]
what is that New York comic-con yes
welcome to Marvel's Ironman VR behind
the script i am josh delay we're gonna
get into this game and talk about all
the juicy good stories gameplay and all
of that so to join me on this stage is
Ryan Payton creative director of
camouflage
and Bill Rosen BP and creative director
of Marvel okay
oh look at that flight look at that
flight Oh stabilized stabilized and
punched out gentlemen hello long time no
see long time no see yeah that's right
readings Josh last day you holding up
okay yeah doing my best doing my best to
but too many too much yelling I like
that t-shirt I'm brand I mean I like
your guys is tha twins twins see this is
pretty cool right alright so let's start
with the basics yeah
for those of these fans who don't know
Marvel's Ironman VR what is Marvel's
Ironman BR all right well Iron Man's VR
Iron Man Marvel Iron Man BR is all about
taking the awesome things about playing
as Ironman the flying and the shooting
and the the rocket punch in the ground
pounding in that three eight three
three-dimensional HUD right and also
being Tony Stark and then smashing those
together with the great things about VR
and PlayStation VR which is those move
controllers so you can do all the flying
and the shooting and the ground pounding
and rocket punching and then also with
the with the VR headset you're in that
three-dimensional HUD and finally with
VR it's there's a sense of immersion in
VR right so being Tony Stark not just
playing as Tony Stark but being Tony
Stark I'm looking down and see your body
and seeing your hands and hearing your
voice as Tony is really all about that
what the game is all about so it's just
not the action and the Iron Man
simulation is also about Tony and that
in that fold triple a level of VR
content in a full campaign as well yeah
I mean simply put I like to think about
it is it's it's the ultimate wish
fulfillment that lets you do what you
pretended when we were all eight and
nine years old and maybe today is
putting you inside the armor when you
put on the PlayStation VR headset it is
just like putting on Tony Stark's a
helmet and yes you and in addition to
that you get to beat Tony Stark you get
to be that millionaire inventor playboy
you get to walk around the mansion you
get to go to all these international
hotspots but there's something special
about you put on that helmet it's the
first time you've ever really got to
experience having that led up hood
you've seen it on screen you've seen it
in the comics but when you put it on and
it wraps around your face
you get to fly and blast as iron man you
really believe because you are ironing I
got to play this game at San Diego and I
got chills when in the beginning where
you see all the logos coming up and
you're going along the water and you're
gliding down exactly the feeling you get
you encapsulated it perfectly but from
the beginning like did you just wake up
one morning and your team was like I'm
NVR done we got it okay how did you come
up with that decision yeah so the way
that the game all came about is that
through pills boss jae-young over at
marvel games he he met me at e3 and he
said hey we were interested in
camouflage working on a VR game and in
the Marvel Universe and we said yeah
we're interested and we came back to the
team they said well but if they could be
Iron Man what could be more perfect for
VR than the Iron Man as a character
right so we went back to J&J said hey
thanks but no thanks Iron Man is our
crown jewel for viajar basically and you
guys are good but you're not to that
level that I want you to be at like okay
challenge accepted
what would we need to do in order to
convince you of that and he said well
you're not gonna get it but the a great
pitch and then also an amazing the best
prototype I've ever seen the VR of VR
for Iron Man and the team just just like
Tony in the cave they're you know
they're their backs against the wall and
they just worked really really hard on
an incredible prototype that in two
weeks really just communicated what what
Bill was talking about that joy of
flight that sense that you are Iron Man
that suit even if the world was just in
grey box right we got that sense that
players were playing as Tony Stark even
in this rough capacity so when we took
it down we we rented a minivan out of
Seattle Airport drove all the way down
to LA with the VR equipment in the
backseat we pitched a Marvel little
thankfully they loved it and the rest is
history
that's right that really shows it at
Marvel we love to give opportunities to
talent across the board in all our
divisions we we have a whole history of
saying to someone if you have the
passion and the desire and the love for
the characters and the talent then we
will give you that shot and they took
that shot and they hit a homerun and we
said you nailed that wish fulfillment
that number
put it on do I feel like I'm flying do I
feel like I'm blasting and from day one
they killed it and we said you got it go
what it was like you were Tony Stark
right someone tells you no and you were
like I'm gonna make this I'm no one's
gonna have basically it pans out
beautifully and talking about the flight
let's get into the flight mechanics of
this sure you nailed it beautifully how
did you go about doing that well we got
really lucky with one of our lead
gameplay engineers Troy Johnson he just
from that first day he was in the in the
VR equipment trying to figure out how to
make this feel natural and that's like
really the the key here is that just
like with Audis design of the suit just
like with a lot of things about Iron Man
and the things that I love about Iron
Man is that it's not just fantasy
there's a lot of there's a lot of
science behind the fiction right and the
way that the flight mechanics work in
our game RV is very physics based we're
not making up a lot of stuff because and
that is like the true secret sauce of
the game is that if we were to kind of
simulate or imagine how flying would
work in VR and have the player do a lot
of stuff that didn't feel natural and
was in physics based your brain would
know you subconsciously you would
actually start feeling not so good right
but the one of the great things about
how our game feels so good when you play
it is because it all is physics based
and when Josh was here yesterday talking
about it he was right he said while the
level of minutiae that the controls have
he didn't expect with the PlayStation
Move controllers and it's true like
they're all based on on proper laws of
physics speaking of the impulse armor we
have some lithographs we're gonna give
out at the end of this panel so stick
around we got a few of them left over to
give out to some fans because I did a
fantastic job with that yeah
oh and just distress who audience why
it's such a big deal
so Adi was the artist who back in in the
90s drew the extremity line in the Iron
Man comic book that Warren Ellis wrote
and really he was the first one to draw
the suit and when you saw it you said oh
it's it's bold it's dynamic it works on
the page but I also understand that
there's a man in there and I understand
how the armor works and so he was owned
actually that was drafted by the MCU to
work on the first Iron Man movie so he's
the one that was
huge inspiration for the MCU so to have
an artist that we love who has done the
comics who has worked in film now to
come full circle we love working with
them again and then to help us design
the armor and then create this print is
an awesome thing and it just shows you
how much the team cares about
authenticity
about Marvel and getting it right and
when you can get the actual creators to
come on board that that's something
special and let's go into this autumn or
a little bit even more details you're
now creating an armor for VR right what
does that process like yeah so just like
Bill was saying we had that that kind of
classic inspiration and a knotty kelp
helped and helped him out modernize it
right but when he's working on the
comics for example I would imagine that
maybe that's where the work would finish
but then the team went and started 3d
modeling that suit and then we put it
into VR and we realized that when
players twist their arms around like
this yeah how does it actually function
and some stuff would break yeah and so
they we call back audience say hey can
you change this aspect of it so the
players can rotate their arms more
properly or when they put their chest
piece out like they've if they pump
their chest it actually flexes properly
over here on the on the clavicles right
and to Audis credit he was not only open
and willing to do it but he's really
excited to do it because we were
actually stress testing how the suit
would work in the real world right yeah
and then yeah that's the magic of VR is
that it everything has to function it
has to work you have to look down and as
Ryan said be able to move your arm in
any direction and that was part of the
the the genius of you working with him
he engineered it just like Tony Stark's
so they're actually functions talking
about the classic inspiration when you'd
look back at the 1970s Ironman suit so
the color language they were so smart
the red parts were the gauntlets the
chess pieces the boots
those were the the hard and protective
parts and then the yellow parts the gold
part of the suit were the arms and legs
the flexible parts so they really
thought it out it wasn't just random
color placement so we were like how can
we take inspiration because we were very
I'm gonna talk about we were very
inspired the whole team by there was a
famous story called demon in a bottle by
David McKee Laney who was the writer and
Bob Layton
the artist and co-writer and that was a
big big big inspiration and that was the
suit in that story so how do we take a
suit that was drawn to D on paper bring
it into the present make it
three-dimensional and then make it work
in VR is quite the challenge
absolutely and thankfully the the you
know the team at camouflage the
developers we were really we were up to
the challenge but only to a certain
point because in our team was trying to
figure out on our own and work with Bill
and working with Tim and to a certain
level we got it we got like the people
kind of blur your eyes you can kind of
see a lot of the similarities but it
wasn't until Adi came in there and then
really added his design background to
really flush it out and and make it a
really clean and powerful looking suit
that we're calling the impulse armor
what I also love is is the team was very
much inspired by Italian sport cars oh
that's right because everything that
Tony makes it's going to work it's gonna
be excellent but it's gonna look good so
there was a ton of pictures remember the
whole mood board and cars so when you
actually look at the chest that whole
chest piece is very much like the hood
of a car that was a lot of the
inspiration everything is streamlined
everything is beautiful everything is
functional but it's sexy as heck and one
last point on it is if you see like the
the black kind of like these what kind
of rubber parts here yeah this is
specifically to allow players to stretch
their arms out and also each player has
different body types and so that's where
a lot of the elasticity comes from for
the players to you know kind of fill the
suit in as they will if they're if
they're four and a half feet tall if
they're six and a half feet tall it
doesn't matter players get to first time
get to be in psvr in the Iron Man armor
the first time ever
how do players get to make it unique to
themselves well yet so a big part of
being you know creating an Iron Man VR
game is that is the Tony Stark
experience the fact that he's an
inventor or genius inventor and giving
players access to that to that garage
right so very early on in the game we we
have players kind of roam around the
mansion and eventually get access to the
garage and that's where they can see the
suit in in in third-person right and
that was another challenging way to face
trying to do storytelling for an Iron
Man VR game is that by virtue of it
being vr if
in most cases you're in first person so
you don't actually get to see the full
armor that often right so we felt like
for the game the garage was that really
important opportunity for players to see
all the work that they've done to
customize the suit to change their decos
to add and swap different weapon types
throughout different augments and then
see their work before they start taking
it on and playing in a first-person
right right I mean that's that's what's
so unique about VR and and and about the
game is that you know in most games
you're in the field you're fighting
you're doing all that action what I love
about this is in addition to that as you
say you get to walk around the Malibu
mansion you get to go into his garage
and there's so much storytelling through
visual things everything was thought
about what's framed what's on the walls
what's on what's on his desk what are
all these items that you can interact
with and look at and they are the team
did an awesome job of really applying
thought to that and it's all specific to
Tony it's all Easter eggs it's all
storytelling so that's another fun
aspect of just being Tony Stark and
walking around the space and and
touching things and looking at things
exactly one thing you mentioned Ryan is
you are the camera it's no less it's not
a third-person camera behind you you are
the camera you are doing the storyline
so how did you just make all these
decisions for this truly immersive
experience 80 years of Marvel history
yeah I think a big part of it was
because you are the camera because you
are the hero in this VR experience we
knew that we couldn't have these big
epic set pieces these third-person CG
cinematics where lots of actions
happening where you got lots of enemies
and lots of super villains on the screen
we really felt because it's VR because
you are the hero we wanted to tell a
more intimate story so we do have a more
limited set of super villains and we
have in that super villains we've only
really talked about one but but also
Mitch making sure that even though the
depth like the scale of the game is
quite epic is that we want to make sure
it's a very personal story to Tony and
that the interactions you have with our
super villains are very up-close and
personal as well yeah
I really like that we focused on the
foes that we really dig deep into that
relationship between Tony and ghost and
really focus on that and really showcase
why ghost is one of the greatest Ironman
villains of all time and even though you
say I mean I think there are moments
when talk about filling the screen with
a ton of villains but there are moments
when you're in you're flying in those
drones or when you're at the Helicarrier
and that drones rubber your choice
pretty crazy you're trying to save the
plane and they're all around it really
shows you how difficult it's like
everyone thinks oh it should be easy to
be Iron Man you're in your armor and
you're just shooting but it's just
because you're in the armor doesn't mean
everything is going to happen
automatically you have to make choices
you have to aim you have to make it
happen
so the armor is just as good as the
person inside it and so that's where the
player comes in how are you as as Iron
Man what are you going to do to your
suit how are you gonna upgrade it what
it's so cool on the on the gauntlets
there's many things we can swap out
there's all sorts of missiles and bombs
that you can pick that give you
different offensive and defensive
capabilities and it's up to you to
decide how are you gonna play what's
your Iron Man right and and and how are
you gonna use those things they don't
just go automatically you have to you
have to decide that's ready to fire at
the moment where you're gonna aim all
that oh hey can I borrow your mic - they
could do a demonstration here one of the
really cool things that the team came up
with was using the PlayStation Move
controls most most games when you're
shooting the game PlayStation Move
you're kind of doing this right but they
thought it's more natural for players to
feel like they're actually holding the
repulsor so you hold the controller's up
like this and so that's how you fire
your repulsors but a lot of like rockets
come out of the like the yeah the
forearm of the player right so they had
this great idea that instead of having
the weapon changed be a button press
what if players shoot the repulsors like
this and then tilt their remove
controllers down and then fire out of
here so it's a that's all credit to the
team and at first I hated that idea and
they beat me down and they were totally
right but it's another example of
immersion that you are actually doing
the motions that Ironman would have to
do
and it's not just Ironman is also Tony
Stark in this game right yeah and
players get to play as Tony store
because well how do they play
differently you got your big action
moments right your big missions that can
take anywhere from 20 to 45 minutes and
in terms of like the different big set
pieces we have and then interspersed
between there you got your Tony Stark
campaign moments and that's where he the
suit comes off and you look down and you
see your full body Tony Stark there and
now you're exploring environments and
you're interacting with a lot of classic
Marvel characters and we want to make it
so it did it wasn't strictly linear
story experience as well because again V
you're a VR and you want to like play
with stuff you want to kind of touch
like kind of poke at the boundaries of
VR so we have these really great set
pieces these these great stages that
players have always wanted to be in like
the mansion like the garage Marvel was
so unique starting back in the 60s when
when they brought the Marvel Age with
the heroes they Stan Lee and Steve Ditko
and Jack Kirby they were determined to
put the human in the superhuman and it
was revolutionary at the time they made
you care about the person before they
got their powers you know you like Steve
Rogers before he gets the Super Soldier
Serum you look you you meet Peter Parker
and you like him before he's bitten by
the spider in our case you know you meet
Tony who care about Tony before he goes
into the cave and so those moments I
think the writing team Brendan Murphy
and Christos Gage who came in later did
an awesome job of making the Tony
moments just as important as the Iron
Man moments and that's what we love
about Marvel we care about these people
but that are inside the uniform we worry
about what's happening up in the sky
because we care about them when they're
on the ground and they're supporting
cast so the all of the scenes are all
driving the story forward are upping the
drama are exploring who Tony is as a
person and again I to talk about that
supporting cast it's not just Tony you
get to interact with his AI Friday there
is of course Pepper Potts
there is Nick Fury who you meet in the
Helicarrier and its really these
different people including ghosts who
really challenged Tony push him forward
challenged him to be the best person he
can be ghost is one that really pushes
him she challenges his worldview she's
saying that no you can't just turn the
page and and and and build upon your
past to try and be your better self
she is the ghost for the past and Tony's
like no all of us every day we have an
opportunity to be our best selves we may
have stumbled yesterday but that doesn't
mean that today we can't get up and and
move forward and that's a very
inspirational thing and ghost really
challenges him with that and in the same
way I think Friday and I think pepper
all challenged Tony she he's got the
sort of support team it's really the
women in Tony's lives who are behind him
who support him who challenged him and
you go on this journey and you realize
you know Tony's very ego he's an
egocentric guy he truly believes that he
himself can save the world that's a
noble thing but he needs to realize that
he can't do it alone and it helps to
have a team around you well should we
queue up the story trailer oh it was
time to show that Tony's at the heart of
this story that's right so we show these
fans of store each other that we showed
earlier at Madison Square Garden which
is gorgeous
it's queue it up right now
[Music]
I used to wonder how you did it
lived in this empire built on pain and
suffering more than a dozen people are
dead after a missile attack involving
Stark Industries why'd you stop selling
weapons Tony I needed to sleep better I
told you your old weapons would be the
death of you starry love what they did
with the place
Friday you get a feeling we're not alone
and you are a ghost from your past
have power I suit for them and we say
don't atone for your sins die for them
20:20 I cannot wait I cannot wait but
let's talk about the inspiration there's
so many comics that I feel like fans can
read what was your inspiration from the
comics to this well so very early on in
the in the process we knew that we
didn't want to just create an Ironman
simulate it we want to create a great
Tony Stark story that and through
through Bill is pretty in particularly
he pushed us to in that in that
direction to making sure that it's a
it's a genuine authentic story where
it's not an origin story of Ironman but
it does it does get into some very like
fundamental aspects of what makes Tony a
great character and then one of those
things is that Tony being his own worst
enemy right so he looked at a lot of
those like those great classic comic
books from the past also some really
great stuff from the more recent runs as
well but for for me particularly about
the demon in a bottle series from the
late 1970s that bill mentioned earlier I
really loved that because it to me
leading up to that point I felt like
Tony hadn't really confronted with a lot
of his own kind of personal demons and
watching him kind of go through that for
me was was really inspiring and I'm a
lot more of those of a fan that of comic
book heroes that maybe is slightly more
grounded so the fact that this
larger-than-life superhero is being
grounded by in this case alcoholism was
was really interesting and I really
changed a lot of my perspectives on on
storytelling and in comics and I think a
lot of people as well and I love that
the team took that inspiration and then
made it their own you know as Ryan said
he looked at a lot of runs he looked a
past classic runs and you mentioned the
current runs and the extreme is Jo the
extremis run even though the current run
by Dan Slott all the elements there and
and the idea of taking those things
internalizing them mixing them up
presenting them in new ways so that you
as the player don't know where the story
is going and so you at you as Tony
whether you've read all the comics or
haven't read a single comic which I hope
all of you never say that but if you've
not read anything you can play the game
and
makes complete sense it's completely
accessible you you you know who everyone
is you know all their relations so you
can play it just hey I'm an Ironman fan
or I'm a VR fan or I'm a camouflage fan
I'm gonna check this out everything
makes sense if you are a long time true
believer it is shocked to the Gil with
Easter eggs and and point backs but
again I like that you took things mixed
them up modernized them made them yours
and it's camouflages Iron Man no thank
you yeah and it's it's so much fun to be
able to kind of just within within
reason and within with it in a
respectful manner just kind of
cherry-picking some of those things that
we really loved about the comics that
fit really well with the story fit
really well with VR and also pay some
homage to some of the the works that
really helped inspire our understanding
of ghosts for example like the
Thunderbolts run yeah bill worked on
there's a very very subtle Easter egg
from one of the comics that he worked on
in one of the missions in the game that
I should not spoil but that's for like
the really hard core so like bill said
though you don't have to have read the
comics to really understand - to
understand it all like the high level
like the the high level of the story
makes sense from beginning to end I also
want to give a shout out to Christos
Gage yeah absolutely wrote this story
amazing amazing talented legendary man
now let's talk about the world building
in the universe of this now players get
to fly around iconic Marvel set pieces
of landmarks well what was it like to
build this wow so yeah building it was
an incredible challenge because like
when we were first you know pitching the
game to Marvel and we had this this very
rough gray box city that was basically
the the origin point of this shanghai
mission that you just saw we thought
well you know we might have to create a
few environments that a little bit
bigger than normal but then once we
realized just how fast the player wanted
to fly at as Tony that's around about
250 miles an hour and that's a very fast
clip to be flying at at a game that
needs to look beautiful and so pretty
early on the art team realized that this
is going to be an incredible challenge
and one that we're still you know facing
to this day the fact that we want to
create these really great-looking
environments that have to be massive in
order to allow the player to fly around
them but the way that they want to fly
so for example this Helicarrier
unit right here this is this this is
more than the size of many missions that
you would play in like a normal game
where you're on foot right this would
yeah this would take up probably three
missions worth of content on an on foot
game and it's fully built it's the top
it's the bottom you can go you can go I
enjoy go through the bottom yeah it's
all designed of of again in VR I'm not
just watching this thing I'm gonna get
up close to it on interact with it and
it has to be 360 360 all the way around
so that was a lot of the inspiration of
designing everything even even even the
characters really designing full-body
what they look like standing there
looking at you foot to toe front back
all the sides coming up close seeing
them from a distance they're all that
thought of building and and the I would
say the environments the people look at
checklist just started with being a
fanboy like if I'm Iron Man I want to
see here's the things I want to do here
the photos I want to face it was just
like when we were little kids like hey
you want to draw an Iron Man comic okay
what do you want to do and that's what
we were we just started as fans in a
room with lists and what would be our
dream Iron Man story yeah I cannot wait
I cannot wait guys my of Marvel's Iron
Man VR exclusively for the PSV are
coming out February 28th 2020 you can
also pre-order in the PlayStation and
you get all of these beautiful for deco
armors as well as one month of Marvel
unlimited terms and conditions apply
check out marvel.com slash unlimited I
mean look at these beautiful be the
original impulse armor and we just did
kind of Easter Egg suit so here's
inspired by his very food first all grey
suit mark one here's one very much
inspired by his 1970s comic book suit
here's a one inspired by the civil
Centurion and then this is the wild card
one more like go nuts and then you get
the ultraviolet armor and you guys can
play this game at the PlayStation booth
right on our left
18:54 play the demo of Marvel's Iron Man
VR exclusively for psvr
last word last sentence you guys want
these people to know about yeah thank
you because one one important point
about the custom decos is that you don't
just see them in first person you know
it's not just about applying them and
now seeing them in the arms you see them
in the garage you see them in third
person as well so players get to see
just how cool and and see just like all
the level of deep
the team has put into it I just want to
say if you love Ironman if you ever
dreamed of being him since you're a
little kid to now this is your chance
you put on the helmet
you are Ironman suit up in February give
it up one more time for Bill Rose Ben
Ryan Peyton for Marvel's Ironman VR
exclusively for psvr